If we're honest there's a lot of hype
when it comes to making passive income
online and so in this video I want to
dispel the myths out there about passive
income and actually prove to you that it
is possible to generate real 24 7 cash
flow from YouTube I'm going to show you
how we do it at think media how I've
been doing it really over the last 10
years when I was just getting started
and super frustrated and didn't have all
the right gear or all the understanding
but how I've really turned this into a
system and how you can apply this in
2023 on your content and you know the
data is out the global digital content
creation Market size is expected to
reach 50.2 billion by 2028. so this
industry of the crater economy and
people making money on YouTube is really
a real thing you know 200 million people
are earning money from digital content
creation right now and Yahoo finance
revealed that the crater economy is the
fastest growing segment of small
business and so this training is all
about the money equation how do you
create 24 7 cash flow using the VRA
system how do you create real passive
income and so if you're fired up for
deep dive trainings like this smash the
like button
um you can see time codes and chapters
and you can check out there's a whole q
a section at the end but I've got six
specific ways that you can generate
passive income with YouTube right now
and I'm going to be talking about the
seven step system we use here at think
media to do this over and over and over
again so we actually can truly make
money in our sleep spend more time with
family reach our goals but I want to
start with this question and that is
what is the difference between those who
struggle and those who Thrive with
online video you know there's multiple
different ways to solve a problem right
if you want to have success on YouTube
there's a good approach there's a bad
approach there's some terrible
approaches if you want to solve any
problem there's lots of different ways
to do it and sometimes if you're
searching for videos online there's a
lot of different people you could follow
there's a lot of bad information out
there and there's all kinds of different
approaches in this video I'm going to be
sharing one approach but as we kick it
off I kind of had some funny uh things I
discovered as far as different ways to
solve problems just kind of to prove a
point I don't know if you've ever seen
the clothes hanger Muffler fix like it's
a way to solve the problem could be a
fire hazard but it may or may not work
but but it's maybe not a very good way
to solve a problem how about the duct
tape drink holder
I mean like you got it like I don't know
if you ever dated a guy and this was his
drink holder you may want to keep
looking you know it's just might not be
or how about the duct tape tape hammock
a little bit of Gaff tape a little bit
of duct tape a couple trees you're good
to go we'll hold you up I'm not sure and
what's the point this is the wife beater
baby carrier um you know I'm a dad now
of a seven month old and a two and a
half year old and so I'm all about that
front pack life but this is definitely a
much more budget way to solve the
problem how about the fan leaf blower
it's an option it's a good you know cool
off after you're done you're working
hard in the driveway and then afterwards
you could use the fan to cool off how
about the um the two dollar spoiler a
dollar 27 for the scrap Lumber 72 cents
for the screws and you're ready to go
you know crush it fast and furious style
or here's my favorite one and the final
one the flat screen TV installation gen
zeers don't even know what we're talking
about but if you're an elder Millennial
like me or Gen X or baby boomer you know
that that TVs were crazy gigantic and
super heavy man it looks good in the fry
but what do you think about this install
I mean you may they're one room away
suffered from from the way of installing
this in the front room and you know the
reason I share this with you is because
there are so many different approaches
to YouTube and I think one of the keys
when it comes to creating real passive
income is actually finding a way to
solve the problem of making 24 7 money
with the way that actually works because
a lot of the things that people are
prescribing on YouTube sometimes they're
just trendy and they work for a while
but they're not sustainable success
sometimes when you just Chase Trends you
may get short-term success but we don't
just want 50 15 Minutes of Fame on
YouTube we want to build a lasting
Legacy and I know that's kind of a big
promise in a world like social media and
content creation but really what we've
discovered here at think media is there
is a better way to get consistent
results with business and ultimately
YouTube and ultimately in life and I
actually discovered this
um in a book called Atomic habits let me
know if you've ever read this before but
this applies to business this applies to
YouTube
and here's what James Clear revealed
those who struggle focus on goals those
who win focus on systems
this will change everything
those who struggle focus on goals see a
lot of people right they have a goal of
growing to a thousand subscribers
getting a silver play button eventually
getting a gold play button on YouTube
after you hit a million subscribers a
lot of people
um of course have the same goals winners
and losers have the same goals
so this book revealed and he wasn't
talking about YouTube but it's true for
YouTube that if all you're doing is
setting goals like I I wanna you know
get a thousand subscribers I want to get
a thousand dollars a month of passive
income
focusing on goals is not going to get
you there winning is about focusing on
systems and here's the quote your goal
is your desired outcome it's good to
Define that but your system is the
collection of daily habits that will get
you there so in this video we're going
to be talking about what are the daily
habits
of creating passive income what are the
daily actions for getting a 24 7 cash
flow machine set up as it pertains to
YouTube you know the problems here is
that winners and losers have the same
goal if you also achieve a goal it's
only a momentary change
this is happening a lot right now with
shorts people are like I have a viral
short so what
I mean that's kind of cool but what
really happened okay I got some
subscribers are they engaged did you get
any money not really not from YouTube ad
revenue and so Sean are you putting down
shorts no I'm just saying if all you
ever do is have I hope I can post my
next viral video I hope I can just have
my next breakout moment I hope I can
chase the next trend on YouTube
that's just kind of chasing a goal as
opposed to focusing on a repeatable
system because goals are ultimately at
odds with long-term success how do we
make this sustainable how do we not burn
out and what James Clear revealed was
that you do not rise to the level of
your goals you fall to the level of your
systems
and so ultimately what we need is a
system the secret to the whole thing is
a system and that's ultimately why
I created the video raking Academy
system it's seven steps I'm going to
show you all seven right now
um but it's seven steps that over the
last 10 years when I earned my first two
dollars and 12 cents on YouTube
that obviously wasn't a ton of passive
income yet and it was actually not even
passive but as I kept refining it and as
I kept posting videos now I've literally
generated multiple millions of dollars
through YouTube using this system and
it's really not just it's like you might
say well yeah it works for you Sean but
that's a fluke accident not really
because we have now thousands of
students that have used these 7R system
to generate YouTube growth but also
passive income so let me just give you a
quick overview and then we'll go into
these six different ways really these
money methods of actually how to make
the passive income because you might be
wondering like where's it actually come
from I know I've heard about this online
I've got family members that are kind of
critical because they're like can you
really make money on YouTube can it
really be like your job or can you quit
your job and do this let's prove it
let's use some real stories some real
examples and look at how the math
actually works and if you're getting
value smash the like button here's the
7R system number one is reverse engineer
you start with the end in mind this is
about Hoosier channel four what is the
video actually about and it's also about
who's your target audience but here's
the most important question based on the
title of this video how are you going to
make money have you actually come up
with a YouTube business plan yet have
you actually come up with a YouTube
money plan yet you want to start with
the end in mind too many people again
they're like okay I'm gonna go viral
grow some subscribers and figure out how
to monetize later
you're kind of doing it in the wrong
order you wouldn't just open up a
business lease some office space hire
some staff and then be like I hope this
works I'm going to figure out how to pay
them later you're gonna actually have a
plan
if you fail to plan you plan to fail so
after we've done that then we do some
research and by the way this seminar
system works at like a channel level
what is my entire strategy for my
YouTube channel but then what we do is
we go through the 7R system for every
video that we post to think media so we
start with the end in mind then we do
some research research in a 2023 world
could include keyword research it can
include Google Trends even before this
we had Ian he was going on Google Trends
comparing a couple different terms in
terms of the positioning even of this
video it can include
um looking at different news
interviewing surveying and getting to
know your target audience it really has
to do with those that are really winning
are actually doing proper research when
it comes to their video ideation when it
comes to looking at what topics are
trending and not just chasing a fad but
thinking about man what keeps the viewer
up at night what are their problems what
are their Ambitions and is this next
video I'm going to make even worth
making then you record the video go and
there's obviously so many details in
there about making a great video that
you know has ever good average view
duration all that kind of stuff then you
release the video and that has to do
with all the optimization title
thumbnail description playlist and card
or whatever else then you rocket the
video now when it comes to rocketing the
video if you've actually done all of
these previous steps well
this takes on a life of its own let me
know if you've posted a YouTube video
yet or how many videos you've posted on
your channel but if you posted a YouTube
video before you know that inside of the
YouTube Studio there is either you go
the video shoots up and it flat lines
that's bad right that's like a Elon Musk
SpaceX rocket launch fail we want to go
straight up but the thing went
and crashed and just went flat of course
a good video we've if you've ever seen
this in your YouTube Studio it's going
up it's going up it's going up it's it's
like a rocket you're like oh man this
video to the Moon come on Dogecoin to
the moon and the video is going up
and if you've ever had a really breakout
video the vertical it might just be
blazing up and it just keeps getting
more views and keeps getting more views
if you have done the first four steps
well then ultimately a video should take
on a life of its own and it should rock
it into the stratosphere when it comes
to going viral getting views or the
other way to look at it which is
definitely what we're more passionate
about is even just slow and steady
growth it might not be like parabolic
straight up what it might be like is
over the next three years it just keeps
getting views over the next five years
it just keeps getting views
and it takes on that life of its own
however we do talk about different
tactics and strategies if you already
have an email list or something or you
have a social media following somewhere
else or use the community tab what are
other ways that you could drive some
traffic awareness and Views to your
video then review it's all about
analytics how do you make data driven
decisions study the video you just
posted in the last 10 videos you posted
what can you learn from that and how can
you
um apply that to your next video and
then there's repurpose and repeat which
is actually now kind of like the Adar
system because in 2023
there's the opportunity to take your
shorts and post them on other platforms
to remix your vertical your horizontal
videos into shorts to be posting
vertical videos on multiple platforms to
be multi-streaming on live streamings
repurposing video podcast it goes on and
on and that's one of the biggest
sections of content we've been adding to
our course video ranking Academy is the
opportunity to have YouTube be your home
base but then also distribute your
content across platform this is
especially relevant for entrepreneurs
business owners you want to get more
leads clients customer sales sometimes
YouTube is a slower Pace uh of growth
for starting but it's still the best
place to plant your flat flag establish
your brand repurpose your content
elsewhere perhaps build your business
more like this month and this day on
Instagram or somewhere else but build up
the long-term Legacy and brand on
YouTube of course then as creators as
well some sometimes you start focusing
on YouTube but eventually expand onto
other platforms that makes your brand
deals more valuable all that kind of
stuff and then repeat is about man how
do I begin again more intelligently and
what are the productivity tips because
you may already be like a little
overwhelmed right thinking about this is
a lot to learn that's why it's a system
it's kind of like it's a process of
habits it's a lifestyle our students are
living the video ranking Academy
lifestyle
they're not just chasing goals they're
leaning on systems you're not going to
rise to the level of your goals you're
going to fall to the level of your
systems that's why we created the 7R
system and so repeat is how do we save
time batch produce repurpose content
marathons you know all this different
kind of stuff and by the way if you're
interested in learning this 7R system
and so much more in depth we have a
limited offer happening right now not
just on video ranking Academy which is
where we teach this but a lot of other
cool stuff that's at vrafam.com I'll put
a link in the description if you're
interested in this at all and really if
you give me a chance and join vrafam.com
I'm confident you'll thank me later
because if you're serious about YouTube
you're absolutely gonna love this and
this is the best offer we've ever done
but here's the question is it possible
to help people and earn real passive
income 24 7 with online video
is it actually possible to to to earn
passive income you know what's funny is
I saw a garyvee video Once when he was
like passive income is BS
and what's super funny is is you know we
had Gary speak at our event last year
and I love Gary but I couldn't more
wholeheartedly disagree with what he's
saying there saying that passive income
is fake it's not real now I actually
appreciate where he's coming from
because he was attacking a lot of people
who would sell you hype or would just
sell you some kind of dream and sell you
something like that you're just going to
get passive income without work that
you're just going to get passive income
uh by just you know uh having some no
work no effort you turn this thing on
and they just travel the world and never
work on it again and it pays all your
bills that's not what I'm saying however
for anybody that thinks passive income
isn't real they're just wrong because
I'm going to show you right now that it
absolutely is real and it's actually
more real on YouTube than anywhere else
because YouTube is the only platform
where your content lives forever
YouTube if you can get passive views in
fact let's just keep going I'm going to
show you the the two-step money equation
here and so we're going to be talking
about my 24 7 YouTube money equation how
I use this equation to get out of debt
and get 2 million subscribers six of the
best ways to earn passive income online
right now and then little known ways to
make more money that nobody talks about
and we're talking about the 7R system
and this is really reverse engineer
remember you should have a money plan
when you start so we're really just
focusing on the first R and this
training and so here's what the 24 7
money equation is another way to put
this would be the 24 7 passive income
equation thing one you need is Evergreen
content
Evergreen content the first thing you
need is Evergreen content this is why a
viral video
is ultimately cool
a cool way to get some views and maybe a
boost to your channel and maybe a few
subscribers but it's not sustainable in
terms of long-term success meaning if
you just have one or two random video
viral videos in your career
but you can't follow that up
and the market shifts things shift let
me tell you this I'm speaking at VidCon
this year in 45 days or something and
that's the largest like content creator
Video Creator event in Anaheim
California and what's fascinating is
I've actually been going to VidCon for I
want to say like a decade now whether as
an attendee originally or as a speaker
for multiple years and Vidcon is
littered or rather it's not littered
because people don't go anymore of of
burnt out famous creators that have
disappeared
they they had 15 minutes of fame but
they didn't have lasting success why
they didn't have Evergreen content
this is a particular methodology by the
way a particular system so what is
Evergreen content are there topics that
people are interested in year round are
there video topics that people are
interested for multiple years in a row
and then a question would be
if you were applying this money equation
even to other social media platforms
does this platform support Evergreen
content did you know that Instagram
doesn't support Evergreen content ain't
nobody on Instagram watching videos from
one two three four five six years ago
ain't nobody over on Tick Tock watching
old tick tocks from six months ago if
you post a buried LinkedIn feed post you
post something over on Facebook nobody's
digging up posts from years ago on any
of these other platforms but they are on
YouTube
what does Evergreen mean Sean well I
grew up in the Northwest Pacific
Northwest near Seattle
and it's a Four Season State summer
spring winter fall snow rain sun and
there are trees though they're called
evergreen trees no matter what the
weather is no matter what the season is
the trees Stay Green
what would happen if you had YouTube
videos that no matter what the season
was no matter what was happening in the
economy no matter what was happening in
the world you were still getting views
and earning money from YouTube ad
Revenue you were still getting views and
earning money from one of the six ways
we're about to talk about it a second
that's ingredient number one
Evergreen content but the ingredient
number two to make this thing work is
you need an automated income Source
because if passive income is going to be
real you need a way to actually be
making money that is relevant to the
viewer and that is aligned with the
content that actually can pay you in an
automated fashion
this then would be an equation for a
real passive income if you can Master
these two ingredients you can create
passive income for you and your family
let's break it down back when I
started getting into video I got into
video for my church in 2003 by 2009 I
started a business called clearvision
media took out a loan bought some
cameras bought a video editing computer
then I started to discover
the early theories in early hypothesis
of what is now the system we teach
inside of our program
of of how to monetize my experience my
knowledge what I've been doing so I've
been doing video for about seven years
and I started doing wedding videos
hip-hop music videos
videos for the YMCA client work right
and I then discovered that I could post
videos on YouTube and ultimately rank
them in search or get them so they're
getting views 24 7 365 and Evergreen
video in this case I discovered that you
could adapt cheap Nikon lenses that were
manual that I purchased off eBay for
super like thirty dollar lenses 25
lenses and the glass was amazing they
were just manual focus and there was a
cool adapter and so I posted a video on
YouTube you can see this video came out
in 2011 and I that's what 12 years ago
by the way this video still gets views
and still earns money and so I started
to do because this was my passion I'm
not saying you do what what uh you
should do the thing that you have
experience in that also fits the
criteria of what we're teaching in this
particular training because if it's not
an evergreen topic and there isn't an
Evergreen Way an automatic income Source
then you can still do cool stuff on
YouTube and it could still be fun and it
still might be according to your vision
it just
potentially won't create real passive
income like we're describing here and so
ultimately I started to do camera
reviews and gear tutorials because that
was my experience for like the seven
years eight years leading up to this
time right here and here's what what
we're looking at Evergreen content
here's what I need you to see with
what's on screen right now this data and
while it might seem unimpressive this
video on screen
got four thousand seven hundred views
okay this last year it grew the channel
by two subscribers and it actually
earned me twenty dollars and fifty eight
cents in ad Revenue
now before you get uh all
right before you go two subscribers it's
terrible Sean well I thought this was
gonna be like a video about like how to
really crush it twenty dollars
what's it's horrible what are you even
talking about well here's what you need
to know about this video
this video is 12 years old
you're watching this right now this
video came out before your kids were
born you're watching this right now this
video came out before you were bored
just kidding you're too young to be
watching YouTube go watch something else
young man
this video is 12 years old do you know
where you were 12 years ago so this
video in the last year grew my channel
by two subscribers this video in the
last year earned directly 20.58 from
YouTube ad Revenue
and this video still earns money from
affiliate marketing which we'll touch on
in a second so this is truly Evergreen
content not just Evergreen content for
like a year or two it's still got 4 700
views 12 years ago so here's the
question imagine if you just had like
one two three four of these videos
imagine if I had to fix the white
balance on the second angle imagine if
ultimately you posted one two three four
five six videos like this that were
generating you views growth subscribers
then you you would see that you're like
I see what Sean's saying passive income
is actually real because I'm not doing
effort on that content I'm not
optimizing that content that content is
just sitting there right now and when
I'm going on a walk with our Duracell
LEDs hyper bright flashlights and every
night my son and I like to go on this
crazy Woods Trail he's the ultimate
Outdoorsman I'm having passive income
and passive YouTube channel growth from
using this system and this is why
YouTube is the greatest platform of all
time
like I'll go into any debate any setting
any environment and prove that YouTube
has a superior advantage to all of the
other platforms that you could be
um ultimately
approving
posting your content on and so here's
what you need
or here's how this video is paying me
the automated income source of this
video is YouTube AdSense and affiliate
marketing
12 year old video
it's still generating money from ad
revenue and it's still generating money
from affiliate marketing and so
we're still going on reverse engineer of
our 7R system but let's talk about seven
ways to make money I think it's actually
six ways to make money with video that
you could attach to this and these are
different ways we're going to be
learning from some of our students that
have actually been using this so here's
number one
YouTube AdSense now you've heard of this
before but the opportunity with YouTube
ad Revenue depending on your channel
topic or your channel Niche like this is
try something new try in something new
and they've grown a pretty sizable
Channel around as a family of five
traveling the world world schooling
unschooling
um they they're on the road full-time
making great videos and making seriously
good money with YouTube ad Revenue
they've gotten I think 44 million views
in this last month so in some cases the
kinds of content you produce you start
asking when you're reverse engineering
like what's the best
way of earning money for my type of
Channel
some channels are never going to get
that many views the the weird thing
about critics is sometimes they're like
oh you're not getting a million views
and they're talking like a business
owner you're like this is this is a tax
planning Channel like it's not gonna go
viral like relax they're they're
applying entertainment numbers to the
education education Niche it's not wise
to do that you want to be thinking
through the process whereas in this case
though they are leaning a little more
entertainment definitely have some big
reach tapping into a big Market RVs van
life travel family these are really
really good topics to tie into and so ad
revenue is a great way for them to earn
money on a new channel you know think
media podcast by the way thank you for
100 000 subscribers we recently hit it
on this very Channel if you're not
subscribed smash subscribe we release
new podcasts every week we do trainings
like this this is just kind of a deep
dive training
and smash like if you're getting value
but
um this channel in two years just so for
full transparency it took us about two
years to earn 71
571 on this channel so again YouTube ad
revenue is pretty good and many of the
videos on this channel continue to get
views 24 7 365. so there is passive
income coming in from YouTube ad Revenue
Nolan malt who is one of the creators
you see him on a couple recent think
media podcast episodes you've seen him
on think media pod on the think media
main Channel
recently had a baby named Luca that's
him and his wife Madeline he's got a
faceless Channel
that has so far earned two thousand six
hundred and eight dollars and 21 cents
so it's a niche Channel he started on
the side using this system just talking
about when you reverse engineer properly
and you pick out the right subject and
you pick out the right Channel and you
pick out the right model again he's not
even in these videos but there it is
possible to earn real money and the
business model of the channel he started
that is again it's what's called like a
faceless Channel or YouTube automation
channel is just earning him and his
family extra money on the side and he
earned um that since October
um until April uh right when we took
this screenshot so April October
November December January February April
what six six months so pretty cool from
a new channel and I mean family baby
juggling work at think media pretty cool
is you could start other YouTube
channels that just bring in passive
income for you and so that's one way to
do it as well uh learn with Zar is is in
South Africa and she actually came on
it's called our VRA show every month we
learn from different creators from
different backgrounds all around the
world sharing their secrets with our
video ranking Academy community so she
is doing uh graphic design simple
graphic design tutorials related to
canva photopia Adobe Creative Cloud
Premiere rush and she crossed that 10
000 subscriber Mark she actually created
like six different flows of income but
YouTube ad revenue is one of the
um flows of income for her what's
actually kind of amazing is as she was
talking to our video raking Academy
Community she was just sharing
um that
this is wild she actually she was
talking about she just uses her laptop
like an older MacBook Air uses her
smartphone and that's all she uses to
create her Channel with all the success
she's already built but then she said
something that rocked our entire
Community to the core she goes yeah and
it's been a wild Journey I'm super
humbled and grateful to be hanging out
with you guys and she goes you know
right now here in South Africa we're on
energy rations so we actually are only
allowed to have we only get power six
hours a day so she goes I'm doing one
upload a day in the window of time that
I have which is only six hours and I
actually am editing and preparing my
video during that time and then I set an
alarm to get myself in the middle of the
night during the other time to actually
do my upload
so just mid training here I want to
encourage you that if you're like
discouraged thinking your situation or
your you know what you're going through
right now feels like an uphill battle
number one I've got empathy number two I
want to encourage you come on there's
other people don't don't have it as good
as as you have it it's really not about
your resources it's about your
resourcefulness and if Zara can figure
out how to build her YouTube channel
past 10 000 subscribers and build
multiple flows of income in South Africa
with an amazing attitude full of joy
over turning every obstacle and every
adversity into opportunity you can too
and so which is pretty wild I just
remember I was like man I was
complaining to my wife earlier that
morning and I just realized I'm not
allowed to complain anymore like I'm
just like as ours out here crushing it
with only six hours of power a day I I
probably should suck it up buttercup and
get to work and so uh she's had a couple
shorts uh break out which is kind of
cool and um she's very inspiring and in
this first one was just YouTube ad
Revenue so let's talk about number two
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is cool because you can earn
money from the products you know love
and use yourself this is Mary from
Mary's nest and some of the things she's
doing is like
she's got a cooking channel talking
about
um kind of like
Farm to Table type of a channel how to
eat more healthy bone broth sourdough
make your own food you know get away
from processed foods and some of the
affiliate programs she's a part of are
things like U.S Wellness Meats mock milk
all these different things here's the
key
she is on her way to a million
subscribers by the way and I think she's
at 800 something thousand right now her
channel is called Mary's nest and she
has all these videos that are evergreen
content recipes for food cooking recipes
and in those videos she's getting ad
Revenue but at times she could be like
hey you know today I'm using the I'm
going to be using Meats from U.S
Wellness meats and if you want to check
it out you can use my promo code Mary's
nest and get 15 off the regular regular
prices or just click the link in the
description
so remember our system
the video is being viewed for years she
has like hundreds of videos on her
channel that are being viewed for one
two three four five years
and then they're connected to an
automated way of making money
this is uh Jennifer from the sewing
report she's done different embroidery
machines that have uh blown up one video
here we'd call this again A ranked video
this brother PE 800 embroidery machine
cost her 650 dollars and she's made at
least four thousand dollars she said in
Amazon affiliate commissions from that
so this video that she made two years
ago is paying her passive income that's
the dream right that's why I I know
you've probably seen a lot of info on
YouTube and a lot of people you wonder
if you can trust I just don't know how
more transparent I could be about this
like yeah and I and I respect if you're
so like yeah but is this real it's like
what what is what else can I show you
like they're making videos the videos
rank on YouTube they're connected to an
automated income source and for the last
two years
the affiliate program for that brother
embroidery machine is paying Jennifer
right passive income
this is Dad verb who has a channel for
parents but Dad specifically and so he
talks about different strollers or
different
um baby products and so what you have is
Evergreen content plus an automated
income Source but this one's going to
blow your mind and let me know if if
you've had any aha moments and smash
like if uh you're getting value out of
this but Sean Chandler actually came up
to me in an event and he said hey Sean
candle is that you and I was like yeah
what's your name he's like Sean I was
like oh Sean and Sean nice to meet you
and he was like yeah I'm one of your
video record Academy students I was
recently able to quit my job and I went
full time and I was like bro that's
crazy you tell me how and he's like well
I actually have an entertainment Channel
I talk about movies I talk about
um Marvel and all this kind of stuff
like that I was like oh cool well like
what are the monetization strategies and
he goes well one of the things that
broke out for me and helped me earn
thousands of dollars was the audible
Creator program and so I actually made a
video about all three Stephen King It
movies ranked so Stephen King wrote the
book it it was turned into a movie a
long time ago there's it was split into
two movies most recently so he ranked
all three movies but here's what he did
he in the video said hey by the way
before we get into it one of the best
ways to experience Stephen King's It is
to read the book maybe you don't read
books so actually did you know you can
get the audiobook and did you actually
know you can get the audiobook for free
just by signing up for an audible
account won't cost you anything and you
could actually listen to the book I did
it myself and it was amazing and if you
actually want to you know sign up for a
free audible account use the link in the
description down below or use my promo
code and and again you can sign up for
these types of programs in this case
this is called at the time I think they
changed the name but it still exists
it's the audible Creator program
and at the time this free offer gave
listeners 15 you got as the Creator
fifteen dollars for every trial
membership that you generated
now hang on for just a second put down
your coffee and take a deep breath
he gets 15
every time someone signs up for a true a
free trial membership by the way
not if they also actually ultimately
stuck with the program
so audible an Amazon company
is paying the Creator fifteen dollars
just to get a free trial
so his way of connecting a video that
people continue to watch the Stephen
King's movie which one should I watch
which one's the best the video keeps
being suggested by the algorithm found
in Search and then it's connected to an
automated income source and every single
sign up gave him fifteen dollars so then
I was like dude that's how you earn
thousands of dollars from that one video
and he goes yeah I've been using
strategies like that from VRA that I've
been learning over and over again on
multiple different videos he's talking
about Batman when a new Batman drops and
that graphic novels
from Batman tapping into that fan base
and all this different stuff you could
do remember we're just talking about
Evergreen content connected to an
automated income Source now another cool
thing I have for you if you're
specifically interested in learning more
about affiliate marketing
we do have a free class at free
thinkclass.com where I actually break
down the math and the full case study
and we don't have time to get into it
here about how I invested a hundred and
thirty dollars and was able to turn it
into over nineteen thousand three
hundred and twenty three dollars with a
single YouTube video I almost feel like
I need to apologize because I kind of
hate content like this on the internet
like you know what I mean it just sounds
so hypey like how I turn 19
000 but it's just honest like that's
like just it's a true case study I'm
gonna show you exactly how the math
works exactly how I did it and it's it's
a deeper dive than even this so if that
interests you at all you could write
that down or bookmark it or save it for
later just go to
freethinkclass.com or check out the show
notes and you can get access to that
um on-demand training as well and and
Hint it really talks deeply about
affiliate marketing but a lot of people
are not using the strategies I teach in
this class
um and these will be really helpful even
if you are already feeling feeling like
you're kind of advanced when it comes to
affiliate marketing free thinkclass.com
is where that's at but number three is
services
and when it comes to Services
um my uh the key here is that this one
is kind of passive but kind of not
because if you do Services which I
highly recommend you use your YouTube
channel
to get awareness to meet people
to then sell your services essentially
as a freelancer perhaps or as a service
provider or as a business owner now of
course to fulfill on those Services
unless you have a team doing it
that is going to take your time so
that's not going to be passive
everything we talked about previously
could truly be passive especially for
potentially you I did nothing of that
video to earn those twenty dollars that
I earned this in this last year I earned
20 no Services no phone calls no way you
know what I mean like it's just it was
just automated money coming in from
YouTube
this one takes a little bit of effort in
fact this first example
um if you've never heard about living in
Dallas with Levi and Travis uh why would
you have if you aren't like shopping for
a home in Dallas but ultimately they've
got a cool Channel helping people buy
and sell homes on in real estate they
recently uh released a book called I
think passive prospecting worth checking
out if you're a real estate agent
especially
but what they call it is they call it
passive prospecting
active
other cool word so it's like passive
prospecting would be leads and customers
come your way passively so it really is
passive income because you're not having
to like cold call put up a billboard do
any marketing in fact the only marketing
they do is organic YouTube marketing not
even paid ads of any kind and the the
it's staggering how much money they've
generated they generated
after six months on YouTube they
generated zero
and the following 12 months on YouTube
they generated 90 million dollars of Top
Line real estate sales which equates to
nearly three million dollars because
real estate agents earn three percent
facts that you can fact check whenever
you want and a really cool crew to check
out that was just from YouTube traffic
and one of my favorite things about that
lesson is it was six months of nothing
so like you gotta jump in learn the
skills it takes time I'm not saying that
this passive income system machine just
appears out of nowhere overnight I am
saying is that this doesn't show up in a
day it's something you work on every day
that when you work the system and you
install these habits and when you don't
just set goals but you actually lean on
the system then they have
endless leads customers clients calling
them now which then they follow up on
with active effort so another example is
Jen Devore richer when she was actually
at 546 subscribers her service is she
actually will put entrepreneurs and
business owners in like a physical
magazine and kind of helps you from like
a branding marketing standpoint where
then you could mail these magazines to
the people you want to reach
um and it's a service people absolutely
love so maybe then you get hired to
speak for
um a a company or a network of some kind
or you send them and they get to know
you it's kind of a personal branding
thing and then they hire you so she
helps people with a particular type of
marketing saying that people love her
services but she wants to attract a
particular type of entrepreneur and so
following the seminar system right she
was able to have an 11 000 week she
actually said I had my biggest new week
in New Revenue with eleven thousand
dollars in new business coming in so to
be clear she does have to fulfill on the
business right and she had to make the
videos up front but now that she has a
couple videos coming out she has
evergreen content and then automated
income coming in from Services which
brings us to number four which is brand
deals and this is Dad verb you know he
makes content for new parents and young
families from a dad's perspective and he
does a lot of stuff on Home Tech baby
products toys and gear for Dad dads but
I do want to say
you know sometimes people think Sean are
you just saying all we should do is like
product reviews or tutorials and that's
not what I'm saying at all
dad verb and his family they do vlogs
they do he's just started a podcast they
do a wide variety of content what we're
learning in this video is we're learning
about a particular type of videos that I
recommend you have in your library
because we all need money for the
mission
so when you have passive income coming
in paying your bills and funding your
internet connection and paying for your
smartphone and helping you upgrade your
camera on your computer and pay for
whatever you want to do and hire an
editor the passive income is money for
the mission but there's a wide variety
of content that of course a healthy and
balanced Creator business can be
publishing and even in our seminar
system this is not the only strategy
that we teach
but the promise of this video is I
suggest you make up these types of
videos because they're the ones that can
actually be very lucrative when it comes
to earning money and so Dad verb you can
see some examples here whether it's Baby
Bjorn review or comparing two different
cradles he does a lot of like smart tech
for
um you know different types of baby
products or children's products and he
also I reached out to him he's got four
brand deals going on at the moment so
this next topic is brand deals so he's
doing a baby mattress brand Spyro water
guns Schick Men's Grooming and different
things in fact one of the things that's
been working for him
is short form content short form content
is one of the most valuable skills right
now and he had one video breakout short
form and that actually was the video
that opened the door for a brand to
start listening to him and actually
landed a lucrative brand deal and so um
he has been focusing on short form
content while also having the long form
content Foundation that we recommend the
most inside of our program right so
ultimately that's also why we've
included we inside of VRA fam which
again that's I don't know if you're
watching this sometime in the future on
the replay but there's only less than 12
hours on April 19th at midnight we're
shutting down the doors to this
particular bundle because it includes
things like our YouTube shorts Master
Class
so I want to make a point here to
suggest that
while Evergreen content and automated
income sources is the dream because now
you've got passive income that allows
you to rest recover not burn out
but absolutely you should also go viral
tap into shorts and do other types of
content that's not Evergreen like Sean
do you only do Evergreen content no it's
not I mean we'll hop on Trends influence
surfing Trend surfing there's a whole
mix of different content that you could
do so this is actually brand new we just
finished recording it's about two hours
like if all you got was this you would
absolutely love everything that's inside
of this so again that's vrafam.com that
is um a special offer that also has AI
for YouTube and Niche Finder and the
shorts master class and Camera
confidence and video ranking Academy and
video creation Made Simple Workshop the
workbook all the different stuff if
you're at all interested in this
definitely check out vrafam.com and
we'll put it in the show notes if not if
we're just meeting don't even worry
about it I just know a lot of people in
our community
um have been on the fence about our
video raking Academy program or they're
curious what it is we've never actually
put a bundle with this much cool stuff
all together for over 90 off and so um
when we do challenges only a couple
times a year we even make an offer like
this so if you've been following me for
a while and you already understand too
man this is is the real deal I know Sean
that you have the best training out
there and that you back it with a
satisfaction guarantee and all that
other stuff check out vrafam.com if you
have any questions and to see all the
details about this special offer but
that verb doing both doing the Evergreen
content and doing
um vertical video right now starting a
video podcast over time you eventually
can do of course multiple things Sean
should I do a video podcast yes but I
thought you said I should do YouTube
shorts you should but I thought you said
I should do long form that's the best
so what are you even saying you should
do it all why are you saying I should do
it all right now no I think if you try
and Chase two rabbits you end up
catching neither but I think that you're
thinking about it wrong if you're trying
to do everything all at once we're
talking about building a Creator career
we're talking about having a system not
just short-term goals so that you're
supporting your family three and a half
years from now whatever happened to
making a seven year plan whatever
happened to thinking really more far out
you know our goal isn't to just do a fad
diet to lose weight quickly that we just
regained our goal is to actually create
a lifestyle that keeps us in a healthy
State and actually a way of living that
keeps us strong and healthy same thing
our goal isn't to just try to like
frantically burn out to go viral one
time our goal is to create habits and a
way of living to lean into a system that
allows us to have sustainable success
and so it's a lot of times not either or
it's and both you know this is Ryan
Johnson and his story's been super
inspiring
he helps busy parents lose weight for
good without giving up good food or
family time and his Channel's
intermittent fasting with Ryan he's a
regular guy trying to get off uh yo-yo
diets so he helps people kind of on his
own Journey
um and he's been sharing his journey
with others our tip here is brand deals
because one of the things that he's been
doing is brand deals and recently this
metabolism device uh was something that
he was able to get a brand deal for
that's one thousand five hundred dollars
for an integrated spot in a vlog he's
been doing a lot of shorts as well and
so different food companies diet and
nutrition in negotiations right now with
Thrive and I asked him you know would
you be transparent to share with our
community kind of your journey you know
he's been our one of our video record
Academy students for I think about two
years
he also thought his success was going to
be a lot faster
um just like we all do I'm gonna go
viral and blow up in the next six
minutes it might take longer than that
but the cool thing is he thought he'd
hit 100 000 subscribers in one year
transparently it took him two
it took him two years he got the silver
play button
um and I said hey you know what is your
business model now what are you doing
and we call this YouTube income stacking
uh 1200 a month from ad Revenue
um 500 to a thousand from Brand deals
and then he started doing one-on-one
coaching with people because they've
seen his weight loss they've seen all
the stuff that's happened and one of the
coolest things he does on his channel is
he just shows that you can still like
ball out and eat these great meals
because of tapping into the power of
ketosis intermittent fasting and so he's
got he's built around a 12 000 a month
crater business
um he's going to be coming on the think
media podcast in the future super
excited about that but as we were
talking he's also like bro I'm just
getting started like I can feel it now
in fact I kind of feel like Notorious
BIG and mace right now Mo Money Mo
Problems right like one of the things
that happens this is why it's so
powerful to be connected to a community
and to be continuing to level up your
education because even once really good
things are happening now you have new
problems how do I scale
you know how do I how do I automate some
of this stuff now it's I'm getting very
busy it's a good busy but like how do I
ultimately delegate and figure this
stuff out and so it's really cool to see
what he he sees a path to doubling his
income which once you start to
understand the system like that becomes
a very practical thing to do this is
plants and Lucia she's
also created all six of these we're
talking about six different ways to earn
money she is active in all six
um but brand deals is another one she's
been doing is well uh number five is
memberships it makes me think of Ben
Azadi from keto camp
there's things you could do where you
create an online course but there's also
you can create a membership so it's you
know of course kind of his start and
style that's what video ranking Academy
is at this moment like there's no extra
fees or anything like once you pay it
off you get it and we do keep it updated
so actually we do need to shift the
model and we are and we're talking about
that as a team that's our course but
what Ben's doing is he has an ongoing
membership
um for
um his brand uh all about keto so it's a
sixty seven dollar per month
um membership and again
passive versus active income he is in
there he's one of the best humans in the
world answering questions bringing in
doctors bringing in scientists you know
bringing in all kinds of different
people love in his community serving
people Mission driven you know his dad
passed away from diabetes and he's on
like this life mission realizing that
that was reversible with education and
with changes in diets and so not just
how it's affected his family but how he
wants to help and change the world and
so he is active at his mission and maybe
that's a big message that I need to get
across as well
there's a couple years ago that I think
my wife and I could have had an exit
wrap from working
um you know financially but well Sean
why didn't you well because that's
ultimately not what we're put on this
Earth I mean of course honoring your
family and spending time with your
community and of course it's your choice
and it's between you and God and
whatever but ultimately
um when we're Mission driven when we're
Purpose Driven and we want to make a
difference life is bigger than money but
you need money for the mission so the
power of the passive income is it does
give you the opportunity to have more
choices and have more freedom and have
more flexibility but Sean you know why
does Ben still work Sean why do you
still work because we're on a mission
you know work's actually a blessing like
when we actually see you know God
created uh he works six days and then
he's rested on the seventh like work is
a blessing sometimes it doesn't feel
that way if you're at a job you hate and
that's why the crater economy could be
so cool because you know again he's
created a community that he can pour his
heart into at a higher level than just
free YouTube content through memberships
and
passively people join
it's kind of like Levi but then of
course there's the active follow-up
which is a blessing but here's the cool
thing this is your choice to figure out
which of these you like best
because for some people they want a
level of complete autonomy
so if you do great YouTube videos rank
them in Search and get ad revenue and
affiliate marketing you don't have a
membership Community to follow up on
it's your choice but if you do have a
deeper level of impact or whichever one
of these fit best with your vision
this is your choice to figure out how
ultimately you want to do this this is
Christina Patterson she has a cool
Channel that's like a a Bible study
Channel kind of like a women's Bible
study Channel she's a wife mom Christian
Bible teacher that founded the
non-profit beloved women and she has an
app that she created so it's kind of a
membership ultimately and you could
either go 113 a year or 13 a month and
this is a really cool
um online Bible studies faith-filled
videos and that's how she's doing it
simply soccer David is helping people
create you know the skills necessary
learn the skill sets and mindsets to
crush it at traditional soccer football
and uh simply Soccer Academy takes
things to another level that be a
membership site and then maybe you've
heard of of course patreon or Channel
memberships Tammy danzo art has
different levels that patrons can engage
at three dollars six dollars a month
eleven fifty a month again passive
income but I'm absolutely aware that
this one is a little bit more of a
tension it's passive but it's also
active you've got the reoccurring
Revenue coming in but it's not to say
that there's not still follow-up and to
be completely transparent with the
YouTube title like this you know is uh
just being clear that passive income's a
real thing
but there's also at times real work or
there's the Synergy of creating passive
views passive growth passive subscribers
and for the business owner or small
business owner that is feast and famine
or for the YouTube creator that goes
through high highs and low lows this is
a pretty important system to learn
because that feast or famine thing
what's nice about everything we're
talking about is again of course you may
have the follow-up you do temmie danzo
does monthly q and A's you know with her
patrons at the 12 level the monthly live
Q A's just with that small group to like
connect with that community
so of course you have stuff to follow up
but what's nice about this is this
recession proves your creator business
this recession proves your business
because you're creating a steady flow of
leads customer sales a steady flow of
subscribers awareness and growth so that
your products Services affiliate
marketing ad Revenue whatever model you
choose has an unbreakable unshakableness
to it that again you're not just like I
got to come up with my next best
creative idea you know like I really
hope I can like that frantic anxious
energy of always just trying to like
make it happen again no I want slow and
steady wins I want that unbreakable form
of traffic because of ranked videos that
can ultimately
um give me a stability that 99 of
creators don't have and then number six
is products and so looking at some of
the other examples
Christina created her own life Bible
Journal
um Ben wrote a book and did an audiobook
so he's got the audiobook this is one of
this is passive income
hard to write a book
once it's done though the book The ebook
and the audiobook can earn you money for
years you know our book YouTube Secrets
um generated as a hundred thousand
copies sold now
now
it was hard to write like we put a lot
of effort Benji and I into it and then
we just did the second edition which was
also hard to write easier but we updated
the book entirely and the second edition
is out now YouTube secrets
however
it was out for four years 2018 to 2022
and then at the end of 2022 the second
edition came out
and it earns over six figures a year
that means it earns over a hundred
thousand dollars a year maybe closer to
200 and that's from audiobooks downloads
audible trials ebooks physical books
because it is self-published which
there's pros and cons but self-publish
can be more lucrative if you hit bigger
numbers and YouTube Secrets punchline is
maybe this is also why people could
critique passive income
uh this isn't you know chat GPT I didn't
say hey like write me a book about
YouTube you know what I mean which there
are people doing that and whatever they
can figure that out for themselves but
this is like Blood Sweat and Tears so a
lot of times the passive income that
follows is the active effort you put in
up front to make something actually
worthwhile
I mean one of the reasons why the book
does so well is because we didn't cut
Corners wrote it rewrote it worked on it
put effort into it it wasn't like
riddled with spelling errors you know
direct to KDP Word document that you
know just like I want to encourage
anybody that wants to write a book to do
it but there's a lot of stuff like if
you put crap out into the world don't be
surprised if the results are crappy if
you really put your heart into it you
know again Ben he actually reads and
studies four hours a day not just like
random business books like medical books
because he's he's about like a human
performance and biohacking and so on and
so forth so one of the reasons why the
book is crushing and and this is an
important message for us to get across
here at think media is I understand we
can get lumped into the crew of like
internet marketers that just you know oh
you're just trying to sell a course
you're just kind of I I respect that
critique because I could see how it
would feel that way especially from
people who don't know us
but this is not get rich quick this is
not looking for some
cash grab rug pull crypto Zoo scam no
this is about building real Mastery you
taking your craft seriously you becoming
really excellent at your work you
becoming truly a person of substance at
such a level that there is value on what
you do
and when that's the case your income is
directly correlated to the amount of
value you add to the marketplace
so then you create an asset like
ketoflex that then doesn't really need
to rewrite because all the stuff is in
there and now this asset is paying him
for years as another way that it's
connected to his YouTube channel
Evergreen content automated income
Source this is uh this and that with
Denise Jordan
so inspiring because she's retired she
wanted to still make a difference make
an impact so she started a YouTube
channel wanted to make some extra money
she has all these different income
sources ad Revenue Affiliates and she's
also brand deals she's also created her
own product this is Denise Jordan aka
the apron Diva all right and so apron
diva.com she is what's cool about the
Creator economy is it's like a blank
canvas for you to share your work your
message your creativity I'm not going to
make aprons like we're not going to have
think media aprons maybe we should we're
not going to do that but like that is
something she loves and she wanted to do
and it's so cool to see her start us
start a business within a business man
when you start building influence on
YouTube and you start ranking videos you
can start writing your checks writing
your own checks you know you start being
able to fund your own projects you start
having people come up to you it's kind
of weird maybe but people come up to you
in the grocery store and they're like
Denise is that you this is super weird
and I don't mean to approach you but
like I've been watching your videos and
they've changed my life I've inspired me
they've got me like this is the
different things and what I love about
working the system is once the views and
subscribers are coming in what do you
want to do what do you want to build
what did you want to create
you know those opportunities are there
for you by ultimately stepping out and
not just setting goals but actually
learning a system developing a lifestyle
and creating habits this my friends by
the way to dispel all the myths on the
internet of like but how are people
really earning money from digital
content creation well we just looked at
six ways and we cover a lot more ways
than that inside of our Academy but
those are six of like the main ways and
now
I'm not saying it's easy
but when you work the system you can see
why by the way that's about a year old
article
over 200 million people are earning
money from digital content creation and
what people what critics and cynics say
is they're like yeah but yeah but not
everybody can have a million subscriber
YouTube channel you don't need that
there's so many smaller channels we had
one message of
um Trevor who got 100 1500 views
not 1500 subscribers when he reached
1500 views because vid IQ sends you like
little plaque like congratulations your
whole Channel just reached 1500 views
and he's posted a message in our group
he said I've earned two thousand dollars
in affiliate marketing commissions
you don't hear stories like that
because
critics would look at his 1500 view
channels and would call it insignificant
I would say can't make money off that
you're not even monetized yet even if
you were you would have made 15 cents
but it's because he's got
the right business model because he
understands the deeper ways right these
alternative options of how to actually
earn money in the crater economy this is
why
despite all the haters this is the
fastest growing type of business small
business type
it is the fastest growing type of small
business
signal Fowler revealed that in Yahoo uh
Finance just reinforced that in 2023
and that might sound weird to you but
when people are like why don't you go
get a real job you could be like like
this is actually a real job like you
know uh not that it's easy and there is
inherent risk with cutting ties with
your nine to five with your corporate
job I don't think it's wise to just take
that leap out of nowhere but the
Practical path from going from full time
to part-time to giving your two weeks
notice to figuring the whole thing out
like it is real and so if you have uh
what was what did you like best in this
training let me know smash like if you
got value and as a reminder
this whole thing uh if you're curious
about learning this in more depth we
have our whole seminar system
um our video record Academy program
obviously we could only cover just the
tip of the iceberg in a training like
this
um and I wanted to make sure to get info
to you like a couple times a year we do
a challenge it's over now but actually
the recordings of our five-day challenge
the five quick tips the five main
sessions those are all included in this
as well so we actually have video
ranking Academy
it's an online course you can take at
your own pace
um we have a lifetime membership during
this offer that's available you get our
entire support team and this is actually
why this program's different than
anything else out there on the internet
all the other YouTube courses think
media is like 22 20 W-2 employees and 10
contractors one of our biggest values is
just supporting our community and not
just having some outdated online course
we keep it actively updated we have the
strongest support and the strongest
community on the internet when it comes
to YouTube education and this
methodology of learning A system that
can create predictable passive income
that doesn't mean you become YouTube
famous and it doesn't mean that you
necessarily will have ever have a big
Channel but what if you have a big Bank
are you okay with having a big bank
without having a big Channel and
figuring out how to build a real
business is it okay to have a real
business around your YouTube channel
instead of just some fireworks for 15
minutes of fame but then you're nowhere
to be found that's really what video
break it Academy is all about and so
this is all ending vrafam.com at
midnight as far as when you also get our
AI for YouTube bonus and our YouTube
shorts Master Class bonus and I won't
take your time to go into all of this
stuff uh right now
um just because I know we're Landing the
plan on this video but as a reminder
this is also backed by our 100
satisfaction risk it risk-free guarantee
and I'm understanding that oh it's just
an online course you just want to sell a
course
uh yeah I do actually
well Sean why would you say that because
I know that this course will transform
your life and I'm so confident
that I fully back it
by 30 days to test out the course so
whether it's 29 minutes from now or 29
days from now if you just email us and
say I'm not happy it's not what I
thought it was we give you a full refund
so Integrity is everything to me you
know my brand my reputation so I back
this thing to just know this is the best
YouTube training available not just
video record Academy but all the other
bonuses but if you're not happy for any
reason you have a full 30 days to try it
out and so you just know when you
interact with us here at think media
like we're super chill man like if
you're subscribed here on the think
media podcast and just engaged at that
level cool like if you want to go deeper
and and actually get the right steps in
the right order and actually just have
the fastest path join video ranking
Academy if it's not a good time for you
don't like we're we're super chill here
but I do believe that this is the
greatest training and that it's worth 10
to 50 50 times what you would pay uh to
enroll in this program and I'm so
confident in that that everything we do
is backed by our 100 percent
risk-free think media guarantee your
satisfaction is everything if you're
interested in jumping into
uh video record Academy during this
limited special so that's
vrafam.com smash like if you got like
lift you got value out of this video I
got so much coffee coming in right now
uh in my me it's hard to communicate and
it's been a lot of challenge sessions
but I appreciate you for being a part of
this training as a reminder we've been
dropping some awesome new videos here on
the channel and so uh if you haven't
seen
um one of our most recent think media
podcasts click or tap the screen to
check that out smash like if you got
value today
um and I will talk to you in a future
video